- HI.
- [sighs]
PFFFT.
THERE'S SOMETHING I NEED TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT.
- OKAY.
- I WANT A DIVORCE.
- [laughs]
HA HA.
GOOD ONE, FORREST.
[chuckles]
- [sighs]
- DO YOU WANT ME
TO MAKE ROOT-BEER FLOATS?
FORREST?
- I'M NOT JOKING.
- WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
- I'M DIVORCING YOU.
[sighs] I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW TERRIBLE IT FEELS.
- WAIT, WHY?
WHY--WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
[breathing heavily]
OKAY.
- WHY NOT?
- YEAH.
- FORREST, THINGS HAVE BEEN
JUST AS GOOD BETWEEN US
AS THEY'VE EVER BEEN.
- WELL, MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING
TO BE SAID
FOR GOING OUT
ON A HIGH NOTE, YOU KNOW?
- A HIGH NOTE?
- UH...
- OKAY, ARE YOU--
ARE YOU SEEING SOMEONE?
- NO, I'M NOT SEEING--
I'M REALLY NOT.
I WISH I COULD TELL YOU
THAT I WAS.
- OKAY, WELL, THEN IS IT
A MIDLIFE CRISIS OR SOMETHING?
'CAUSE WE COULD WORK ON IT
TOGETHER.
- [groaning]
- I'LL BE HERE FOR YOU.
- WHY DOES THERE HAVE TO BE
A REASON?
- WHY--WHAT--THERE HAS TO BE
A REASON, FORREST.
- STOP LOOKING FOR A REASON!
WE HAVE TO GET DIVORCED!
- WHY?
- ENOUGH OF BEING MARRIED!
I KNOW THIS IS VERY HARD.
THIS IS REALLY HARD.
THIS IS A LOT HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE.
- [crying] YOU DON'T LOVE ME.
- NO, LISTEN, I REALLY DO.
- THAT'S IT. YOU DON'T LOVE ME.
- NO, I REALLY DO.
I REALLY DO LOVE YOU.
- OH, MY GOD, ERIC.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT ERIC?
- AH, YEAH.
[groans]
[huffs and puffs]
HE IS NOT GONNA LIKE THIS.
- HE'S NOT GONNA LIKE IT?
THAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
HE'S NOT GONNA LIKE IT?
- OW! OW, OW, OW, OW!
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT, LOOK,
PEOPLE GET DIVORCED ALL THE T--
- DON'T TOUCH ME!
YOU ARE GONNA DIE ALONE!
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
I LOVED YOU MORE THAN ANYONE
WOULD LOVE YOU!
- YEAH.
- YOU'RE WEIRD!
SO GET OUT OF HERE.
- WELL, I THOUGHT
I WOULD SLEEP ON THE COUCH.
DO YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY CLEAN SINGLE SHEETS?
- I WANT YOU OUT OF HERE.